we've got a very busy agenda
um so we will make a start
um and get through it
um henceforth so attendance is I'm not
aware of any apologies and we've got a
full house from what I can see other
than Graham Bentley who is on
um annual leave this week item two is
questions from members of the public of
which there are none item three is
Declarations of interest if there are
any please
um indicate now
no item four is Matters from Council or
overview and scrutiny committee Council
acting
yeah just just one thing really and I
know that you have this on your agenda
the uh draft budget
um so just to inform the executive and
and other members who might be listening
is that
um budget scrutiny will be on November
the 29th and December the 1st
and I think all members
will be invited
um obviously not the executive
okay thanks councilor Acton um and we
will make sure that there is a good
attendance from the executive as well to
answer any queries item five is UK
shared Prosperity fund councilor Patel
please thank you leader
the UK shared Prosperity fund is a new
domestic government fund billed as the
replacement for European funding that we
can no longer access the overarching
ambition of the shared Prosperity fund
is to build Pride a place and increase
life chances in the UK
emphasis is also being placed through
this funding on the recovery of our high
streets post-pandemic
gmca has been identified as the lead
Authority for this funding it will
administer 84 million pounds
provisionally allocated to the region
over the next three years
set out within three investment
priorities this report sets out
trafford's proposals within one of those
priorities communities and place
with just under 1.8 million allocated to
Trafford we have identified a number of
projects that recognize the Ambitions of
this funding and reflect our local
priorities
these projects are summarized in the
report and set out in more detail in the
appendix
briefly we are looking to invest in our
town and Village centers we want to
support our Greening Trafford Park
project we want to commission physical
activity and creative projects Public
Health initiatives link our libraries to
wider Community activity and support our
marvelous local Heritage section
in relation to the following report I'm
presenting we are also seeking funding
for a social value coordinator
I'm truly delighted to be presenting
these products to exec today they are
ambitious and I believe represent a
creative use of the funding available
we have submitted these proposals to GM
and the region now await approval from
government I think therefore it's
appropriate at this point to offer a
caveat just like the leveling up agenda
the government has gone very quiet on
the UK shared Prosperity fund whilst the
toys have imploded into Civil War local
authorities are hanging on every word of
this week's PM prime minister or
Chancellor for any Clarity or Assurance
over this funding we have had no
meaningful updates for some while
in such perilous financial times for
local government I would like to
reassure the executive that here in
Trafford we have done everything asked
of us to try and secure additional
funding for our communities we have
always and always will act in good faith
all we need now is first for the
government to keep their end of the
bargain
finally I would like to thank officers
in the inclusive economy team who put
these proposals together I know it's
been across Council effort
if the government wants to go for growth
we have these proposals and three
leveling up bids ready when they are
thank you
thank you councilor Patel any questions
or comments from members of the
executive
questions or comments more widely
counselor but please
thank you Lydia uh it's good to know
what that with the government shared
Prosperity fund allocation none of GM
councils are required to provide any
level of uh match funding
but I have two questions which I would
like to put please I mean bearing in
mind uh I mean with reference to 5.2 on
the table 2 which gives the allocations
bearing in mind that the Council made
its bid around corporate priorities and
local needs why have we ended up with an
inequitable allocation of around 1.8
million out of 27 million across 10
greater Manchester authorities
and my other question is uh on power 2.2
within the gmcas breakdown of the 84
million pounds uh funding includes
relatively High management costs of
nearly 3.4 million pounds does this
figure then include contingency funding
and councilor Patel and potentially
Richard as well thank you I think it's a
jolly good job we don't need to provide
match funding currently
um
the allocation I I believe is fair this
is only the communities in place
allocation so there are two more
priorities
um skills and
local businesses and people and skills
apologies so we will Trafford will
receive further allocations through
those pots
um the the costs of administration
Administration I mean perhaps which you
could could help with that but it it
will need administrating it's 84 million
pounds of GMC CA will need to cover
their costs
um just on that point perhaps uh the the
idea of this funding isn't isn't meant
to be targeted particularly at Capital
funding these the government is trying
to secure Revenue projects through this
so largely that's reflected in our
projects
um too so that's largely employment and
research through our projects Richard do
you have any comment on the gmca
no other than to say that the management
allowances in accordance with government
guidance
thank you any other questions or
comments I think councilor Jerome did
you indicate
thank you later just a very quick
question of with the uh I welcome this
fund and I'm pleased to see it's being
spent in the right areas to
um produce hopefully good results but I
just wondered with the Savage Cuts we
might be facing to our budget imposed by
this government will this undermine any
of the the funding received from
um the shared Prosperity fund
Lisa allows you Standalone projects
um that we're trying to
sort of
draw out away from our usual budget so
hopefully not
um
they're not nice to have either they're
really important projects so it will be
a challenge it's you know in the grand
scheme of what we've lost and what we've
probably set to lose again 1.8 million
whilst it's certainly not being sniffed
at at all um it isn't isn't great levels
of funding for local government
and Council Miss Batman
uh thank you leader
um 5.5 is um table four the Town
Center's investment program
um could I ask is is there a strategy
for after the funding has been spent
and within that um that section
um there's going to be a project manager
will that project manager be a fixed
term contract and would the role be
similar to other other similar roles
within GM within the other authorities
I don't know the exact um it's likely to
be a fixed term contract
um it doesn't certainly replicate
anything we post we have in in Trafford
in in that regard
um follow-on projects we we continue we
always strive to to apply for and secure
funding for our town and Village centers
um so you know Pope who's who's to say
what's coming down the line you know we
go for everything that's going really
can and Richard anything just to add to
that around the contractual arrangements
for the staffer staff member uh no I
would imagine it will either be a fixed
term uh contract oh we will be freeing
up results with one of our existing uh
project managers and using that that
resource but well the the time will be
limited to the funding that we've got
available yeah I could also ask um The
Greening Trafford
what
what's actually in to do with green
vibrant spaces
that's um I think it's in the the second
section with on page eight
[Music]
Richard do you want to just give an
overview of that work if possible I mean
it may be because clearly it is a it is
a header rather than a specific detail
of work we may want to follow up outside
the meeting but if there's anything that
you can add uh specifically at this
point but I think I think given the uh
specificity of the requests we might
want to to take that offline yeah I'm
happy to brief you separately on that
Council Blackburn we have commissioned a
piece of work that's been done on um
Green in traffic Park think about how we
deal with carbon neutral and agenda etc
for Park up for uh the rest of this uh
Century part of that is around how we uh
better use of the green space that there
is already in uh traffic Parker we
encourage our active travel and other
forms of travel uh what we want to do
through the shared Prosperity fund is
then take forward the piece of work that
we have done into out some actual
specific projects on the ground so it's
more it is more about it there is more
to it than just the making better use of
green spaces but that's a part of the
project but I'm happy to briefing could
you just um sorry Linda sorry to
interrupt I will allow one more but I'm
really conscious we've got the budget
and I'm going to ask everybody to be
mindful of that in the questions go
ahead just in the next section active
Trafford there's um a budget of nearly
260 000 pounds and obviously it's it's
not in physical activity movement why
the health Etc will any of the money be
spent on reopening Kingsway Park play
area that's been chained up for two and
a half years
um let's well no because it won't relate
to it doesn't relate to Parks budgets um
so no no it can't be applied to Kingsway
Park um the park that um suffered
repeated vandalism I believe there are
local councilors there are working
um with our Green Space officers to look
at a different approach
um and to draw together a friends of uh
Kingsway Park to try and develop a
master plan there I'm not sure that it's
the space for
formal play equipment that I'm dipping
into my own portfolio there okay thank
you thank you
um okay are there any further questions
on this item
okay recommendations are as set out in
the report can they be agreed please
thank you item six is the social value
Charter councilor Patel again please
thank you leader
through the activities of star
procurement we are already we already
take an ambitious approach to social
value it's something we take seriously
as a local Authority and we recognize
the need to continue to strive towards
better
this report takes us to the next level
and seeks to truly embed social value
into all the activities of the council
the adoption of our social value Charter
will also provide Clarity to businesses
and to the voluntary and Community
sector around the coordination and focus
of social value activity
the social value action plan will
provide the means to Monitor and drive
social value activity across the borough
following consultation we have drawn up
areas and priorities that the voluntary
and Community sectors have identified in
Trafford that they would like to see
become the focus of social value
activity
broad themes have emerged around
tackling isolation addressing poverty
providing food support help getting into
employment improving links between
Community groups and businesses
the social value chart it provides for
the first time in Trafford a practical
list of areas where businesses can focus
their social value activity just a
snapshot of examples include through
providing skills and training forging
links with local schools supporting
volunteer efforts choosing local
suppliers recognizing that the
environment is an asset that needs to be
valued and protected playing fair with
smaller suppliers sharing buildings
vehicles and so we can truly create a
culture where business working with
communities in the third sector is the
norm
this is a challenging time for business
in Trafford but I know that many so many
of our businesses are committed to doing
good
I would welcome businesses taking a look
at the charter and seeing where their
activity and resources can support local
communities
again I'd like to thank officers for
this piece of work we hold some hopes
for the security for the securing of the
UK shared Prosperity fund for a post
that will look to embed and drive this
Charter across Council activity
businesses and local communities thank
you
thanks Council Patel any questions or
comments from members of the executive
questions or comments more widely
councilor Jerome please
yeah we welcome this report and you
using these really larger contracts to
to get this social value it is a really
good thing I just wanted to ask it
whether we do and we are going through
procurement and signing new contracts
can we also demonstrate that we're
looking for carbon emission efficiencies
and reductions as well and these can be
clearly demonstrated in in the contract
I believe we do we that's uh something
that I think we can improve on alongside
social value is how we drive that is
something that we think about but I
think that there's a piece of work that
we want to do now in the back of our
carbon neutral action plan to think
about it is there a way for us to do
that uh embed that further announce that
further
any other questions or comments on this
one councilor Blackburn thank you
um on the social value potential
activities it mentions working with
schools
um so that young people develop better
better skills when they leave school
um as all but one of the schools our
academies and if if we're asking that to
be a sort of a change in the curriculum
how how can how can we
progress this
[Music]
I think it's it's not so much um
changing the curriculum it would
possibly be whereby schools are looking
for sort of volunteer opportunities
local businesses could provide that
perhaps local businesses could provide
um skills and resources into a school
um work experience
sessions educational sessions provided
at school so we have good links with all
our scores Academy or not and it's just
through this we're hoping to forge those
links between local businesses and
schools too
okay
not seeing any other questions or
comments
um I think this is a really positive
step forward for us actually
um and very grateful to everybody
involved including um at Star but the
recommendations are set out in the
report and they be agreed please
thank you
um and thus begins councilor Ross's
Marathon for the evening
um item seven proposed changes to the
council tax discretionary schemes
councilor Ross please thank you leader
members will recall this came to an
earlier meeting and the consultation has
now been completed and equality's impact
assessment carried out which concluded
that no specific groups were adversely
affected therefore I'm seeking approval
from colleagues to proceed to implement
the changes to council taxis the council
tax discretionary scheme from April
2023.
members will note that we're also
looking to align future long-term empty
home premiums with the leveling up and
regeneration Bill changes we are also
looking to increase the hardship fund
and available to any groups that are
left suffering financial hardship the
results as a result of the changes that
we're proposing to our discretionary
schemes
um so I'm just seeking approval from
colleagues thank you thank you councilor
Ross any questions or comments from
members of the executive questions or
comments more widely
no recommendations are set out in the
report can they be agreed please
thank you and item eight is draft
Revenue budget proposals for 23 24 and
the medium-term financial strategy
um 24 25 25 26 councilor Ross please
thank you leader so we are at that stage
of the budget year where I am presenting
the draft proposals for consideration
this evening before they go beyond
before the excrutiny committee and come
back to us in February where we agree
our annual budget for 2023-24.
um just going through the the papers as
briefly as I can we're looking at a net
revenue budget of
209.15 million for 23.24 as part of the
budget work that we've done we
identified that a gross budget Gap is
estimated for next year to be around
25.82 million which is a considerable
sum of money this report sets out how
we've closed that Gap to 8.52 million at
draft stage which is still a
considerable sum of money
taking you through the budgets section
one sets out our approach to the budget
section two sets out the financial
backgrounds and I draw members attention
to section 2.2 which sets out the impact
of austerity measures since 2010 with
cumulative budget gaps from 2010
reaching
263.39 Million by 2020 to 23.
Section 3 sets out our assumptions and
again can I draw members attention to
settings unit
3.2.3 we ask where we are striving to
keep up to date these papers up to date
as possible with reference to the
current prime minister's disastrous
growth plan and the presumption that we
will still have a statement from the new
Chancellor on the 31st of October 2022
and it is highly likely without wanting
to speculate too much that we are facing
local authorities across the country
being forced into more austerity
measures by the national government
section 4 sets out the measures we've
considered to bridge the budget Gap so
far this work will continue between now
and the final budget as we seek to uh to
get to bridge that 8.52 million pound
Gap and we don't assume that we are
going to be receiving a generous amount
of support from the government finally
sections five six and seven set out the
robustness and risks school funding and
budgets and our Capital strategy program
for the years ahead
I'm conscious that we're presenting this
at a time of great uncertainty with a
concern that public services will have
to take further Financial strain as a
result of national failure of leadership
rest assured we in Trafford continue to
take our responsibilities very seriously
and will produce the balanced budget in
February 2023 I'm obviously happy to
take any questions at this stage will be
very heavily involved in the scrutiny um
process but would ask at this point that
executive agree recommendations a to H
and finally and most importantly would
like to thank Graham Dave the ydot
senior leadership team officers and
colleagues who've helped us to get to
this stage so far in watch continues to
be an incredibly challenging budget
Journey each year thank you thank you
councilor Ross and Echo those thanks to
in particular our staff team here this
has been a particularly challenging
process to date acknowledging that there
is work still to do but are there any
questions or comments from members of
the executive questions or comments more
widely
I'll start with councilor Morgan
uh thank you leader and if you don't
mind how as you probably can imagine I
have a couple of questions
um if I can just ask an understanding
question first
um Council I said I appreciate Graham's
not here to um to ask there's 3.85
million which is
um realignment of Treasury management
budget what does that Translate to
um page 52 sorry
okay with that we're looking at ways of
um it's it's marginal revenue and we're
looking at ways of in the short term
supporting the next budget for the next
couple of years with a move to changing
that strategy in the longer term so
still there's some more more work to do
around that time and it will come to
council once that works being fully
completed but that's where we're at this
stage I don't know if Dave if you want
to say anything more on that particular
line
the main principle of that is just the
real look at the depth profiling and the
non-investment profile like So that
obviously changing the interest rates at
the moment of an impact on that so it's
abundant of measures within that
category of Treasury management
um that as a counselor us has already
mentioned we'll bring back the uh the
review of that which has got to fit in
with the potential code set out we're
under one of the Sip for guidelines so
all of that has to fits in with the
legislation so we'll bring back those
proposals
um in further detail as approved
Prudential code
okay
so if I'm not entirely 100 but
effectively timing is what we're looking
at in terms of that profile
give or take
yeah so yeah we're looking at the
profiles of our friends is our if we can
see how the length that's how we pay the
debt back and the likes of that whether
we can do a short-term adjustment to
that to help us through this the rough
time and hopefully get back to some
normality
but thank you thank you no I think I
think I've roughly um roughly got um
where it is
um there's a couple and they've got a
couple of details I'm not gonna ask
without Graeme here
um
but
um
there's a few assumptions within the in
the modeling so for example there's a
Assumption of the six percent pay Rise
um pay award there is
um one percent growth in the council tax
base
um and then there is a question also the
point around the vacancy management
um 700 000
um I've got a question about but that's
a mother hat on um Street lighting
um and it's just kind of if counselor
Ross could focus what he thinks are the
key risk items around this because
obviously it's a very big gap and I do
totally appreciate that what is that
what has happened to be managed by by
Council Ross and the travel time Finance
team but there's still an 8.5 million
gap and it's what risk is there because
there's a couple of items such as there
was a review of demand and placements
looked after children with a million
pounds
I don't know what that means and I'm
sure there's a lot of work that's being
gone into that but it's just trying to
understand where the risk really is on
this um budget presentation which I can
imagine there is there is a level of
thank you
thank you
there'll be individual items which
you're going to go to depth during the
scrutiny process and anything outside of
this room if you want to bring to us
we're happy to to elaborate on in terms
of risks the key ones that I see that
the ones that we've gone through and
presented at draft stage I think we're
as confident as we can be around those
proposals that we've set up we've really
kind of fleshed them out looked at the
worst case scenarios that aspect the
biggest risks for me remain inflation
and the impact of energy which is is
very difficult to get a hard figure for
I know that there is um a current
support scheme in place for this year
but you have to look for next year in
terms of the energy
um ongoing contract inflation that comes
through you know what we pay out in
contracts the ongoing impact of
inflation on the potential Capital
program and how that impacts on there
um the further big risk for me is what
we get back from the government in terms
of settlement and that is where we will
all be watching the statement at the end
of this month and obviously then at the
end of the year for the settlement to
see what money comes in to support local
governments across the country so when I
look at things the proposals that we're
putting forward yes there's going to be
time for scrutiny members to dig into
see if they pass the common sense test
see if there's any suggestions that
people can have around them but actually
the major risks I see are the at the uh
the macro economic level with the
inflation with what central government
is going to do to support us that's
where we're going to continue between
now and budget time itself looking at a
series of proposals that we can
introduce if we have to to bridge that
Gap but ideally the budget that the
government will be um will be supporting
us as we um as we Bridge the 8.52
million that we've got at this stage
foreign
it's relating to this about 500 Grand
off savings across different pots for
Street Lighting on page 51 and 52 and so
obviously
for those of us who've been been here
that time two years ago some of those
proposals were brought in and after the
budget
um we
um reverse those decisions because of
worries about personal safety
um so obviously though I don't think
probably in the public any there's
um any less worries about personal
safety and crime so
um it's the risks relating to those
probably not from a financial point of
view but more from a public safety point
of view around those
um proposals at this stage
thank you again obviously this will be
taken through the scrutiny process where
people where members will have the
opportunity to raise us I know that
there are a number of concerns about
public safety and the potential
implications of uh of of these measures
and we'll be working closely with groups
around these sets of proposals there are
no easy decisions as I'm sure you
appreciate councilor Morgan we're in a
situation now where after 260 million
pounds of budget gaps we've got a
further 25 to look at today with some
uncertainty around the general support
that we're going to be getting from from
central government so each decision we
take now is likely to be a much tougher
decision than we have had to do well
there's obviously be many in the past
but you know they are getting harder to
make these decisions but we are now
going to go through a process where we
will be working with members across the
council obviously very clickings here
from other interested groups about our
set of proposals here but ultimately we
do have to come back with a balanced
budget in February and that is what we
will do
okay I'll come to councilor Jerome
people will appreciate that councilor
Morgan is the shadow executive member so
has afforded a number of questions we're
doing okay for time but I'm just asking
people to to bear in mind if I do start
to ask them to bring their questions to
a close that is uh the reason why Dave
did rather well
um out of it but Council Jerome
thanks leader
um the the cuts that um the government
are forced on uh councils is cruel and
and completely wrong
um we've got to make 8.5 million pounds
of savings and we've got quite a short
time to do it which is going to
obviously mean some very tough choices
for this Council I'd imagine those tough
choices will go beyond the two scrutiny
meetings that we're having in the end of
November and December and I wondered how
the council will keep taking councilors
through this process making sure that
they're aware of the choices you're
having to make
um because I'd imagine they would be
quite brutal and my second point is not
quite related to the budget so I'll make
it quick but uh reductions of 50 for
staff car parking up until
um April the right choice in terms of
our climate and sustainability
priorities and are they fair to all
staff
um so I just wanted to ask that question
as well
thank you very much yes you rightly
highlight the the Gap that we've got to
go just to remind members that we have
already closed that Gap by 17 million so
going from the 25 and a half million at
the start of this process with the gross
Gap to 8.52 million now and
yet we continue to live in very
turbulent political and economic Times
so as and when we need to look at any
potential other saving or investment
term proposals we will bring them back
I'm more than happy to engage with
members across the piece as we get
towards that balanced budget in February
in terms of the um the staff parking
charging I think that was done in very
good faith to recognize the cost of
living crisis but I do hear your views
on that and I'm sure they'll be
considered in future as well
um further indications
uh Council of Blackburn
4.3.4 it mentions changes to staff terms
and conditions could you comment on that
please
it's actually on patreon 89 or 35
whichever one you're looking at
it's about a third of the way down
okay so in terms of in terms of this
anything that we would consider would go
to a consultation with with staff at the
moment our work is around vacancy
management and and how we look at things
that way but
as I said to colleagues these things may
come back into play in future but we
would do that with our staff with our
trade unions and consult that way but at
the moment
the measures that we've looked at are
around the vacancy management area and
other waves of of putting less pressure
on our budget by managing our vacancies
thank you um
I think it's fair to say that that
nobody actually enjoys the the rigors of
this process and the uh those of us
who've been on the council for a number
of years have been through
um a lot of those those rigors it um
it's harsh and it's cruel and it never
feels Fair
I just don't want to ask this year with
there being so many variables more more
variables I think that than ever before
how confident are you that we that that
we confirm up this budget uh
realistically when those variables are
still varying or being variable
um how confident are you that you could
do it in good time for for a good
scrutiny in good time for Budget Council
and in in most importantly in good time
for the implementation of the budget
thank you I appreciate you recognition
of how much how many variables that
we're having to uh to face this time
round and um in many respects that I
think covid that year was was difficult
but this is on a whole different level
in terms of what we're having to to rely
on in in National support and it may not
or it looks likely it's not going to be
there in the senses I am confident we
will get to February with a balanced
budget we will do that in partnership
with our colleagues in scrutiny
the finance and change board which was
instilled or instigated in February and
has been working up over the past few
months there's some work programs that
we're doing in there and that will
continue and we will if we need to bring
forward proposals we will make sure we
do that in good time and we'll make sure
that they've um they've gone through the
the best possible makes sense tests that
that we can do it's incredibly
challenging it is a really really
difficult set of
um circumstances that not just our
Council but councils across the country
find themselves in but we're fortunate
here in Trafford that we've got
a team in finance who are at the top of
their game I I would say and I heard
this from another meeting that you know
that they're the best of Greater
Manchester as far as uh I'm concerned I
know of us uh agree with me in that
we've got a superb set of offices and
we've got a an executive team and wider
Council of membership that are dedicated
to the residents of Trafford wants to do
the best buy them so all of us working
together will get there by February and
as soon as we have if we need to come
back with other proposals we'll make
sure that we do that in a timely fashion
so that they can be scrutinized
thank you councilor Ross um come to
council Acton next
yeah thanks chair all I wanted to say
was that
um although we've we've got two meetings
scheduled we are flexible in terms of
um scrutiny and I know that uh councilor
Ross and the finance team are you know
they they are very committed to coming
along to uh scrutiny
um they have been in the past and have
have no doubt that they they will be in
the future so we we will do the best job
that we can and we do have that
flexibility
thanks councilorant and any other
questions or comments
counselor Wright
uh thank you later just just a very very
quick Point relating to uh 2.2.5 to
welcome the draft adjoining the group of
the F20 group lobbying for a fair fair
funding review
um and just to say that obviously that
is a cross-party
um group of local authorities and given
it to cross-party group of local
authorities it would be very helpful if
the conservative group in Trafford would
also help to Lobby its own government to
give Trafford Affair
um funding part given how much impact
that would potentially have on our
budget thank you leader thanks councilor
rights I think what I would say about
the F20 you're quite right that it is
um cross-party it has
um shall we say woken up in recent weeks
we had been trying to make contact with
them for
um for a little while to try and agree
on some joint lobbying it is cross-party
and to be fair
um under the previous administration we
always played a full part in the
afternoon entities lobbying work but it
is undoubtedly the case that that we're
government to listen to the advice and
exasperated Cries From members of the
F20 and move us up to
um
not
um even what would necessarily be an
average funding level but 90 percent of
that we would be some five and a half
million pounds plus better off per year
so it is an important piece of work and
I do know because I agree to put my name
to an email last week that there is
um work on going in that regard we are
also looking at some
um specific lobbying for Trafford both
with
um the Secretary of State whoever that
may be in due course with our own
parliamentarians to look at what help
they can provide and indeed as the
beginning of a dialogue with residents
to set out the scale of the challenge
that that we face I do just want to
finish because I didn't see any further
indications by pointing out that
although there is a long way to go we
have actually already identified savings
above the initial budget Gap that we
anticipated having
um this time last year and indeed in
February inflation has taken its toll
along with the cost of living on
Trafford Council as much as on
trafford's residence and to that end
just a final thank you as councilor Ross
said to our staff here because to have
reached that point when 16 million
looked insurmountable
um back in February to have already gone
around 1.5 million beyond that and then
to have to face up to the fact that we
have a further 8.5 million to find shows
that everybody has gone above and beyond
already and given the scale of the work
to do I know that we will all need to do
so again in between now and February so
thank you to everybody for your
contributions and in particular to
councilor Ross
um for his work to date on this
um the recommendations are as set out in
the report can they be agreed please
thank you
um item nine is the fair price for care
residential and home care and nursing
homes 23 24 consultation councilor
Carter please thank you leader um this
is just to update the executive on the
recent and planned activity around the
fair price for care and also the fair
costs of care which is an annual
exercise and in previous years we've
been applied an inflationary uplift
prices and then we changed that 2019-21
but we're reverting back to the
inflationary uplift with consideration
of the outcome of the fair cost of care
exercise which maintains the council's
commitment to the ethical care Charter
by ensuring Ring We maintain the
increase in prices
we will consult with providers to set
out in section two of the report and we
will present a report to the executive
in the December detailing the outcomes
of that exercise
we're also undertaking the fair cost of
care exercise which we're required to do
to find the real cost of providing care
by working closely with local providers
we've employed an independent
organization to collect the data and the
return rate for this has been relatively
low but the task of analysis is complex
um the test should take about six weeks
and then it will be submitted alongside
a provisional Market sustainability plan
so executive is recommended to note the
detail in the report and I'd like to
thank the officers for their support in
preparing the report thank you thank you
councilor Carter any questions or
comments from members of the executive
questions or comments more widely
uh councilor wetton
uh just a quick comment to say
um the timing of this I think it must be
perfect
um because of the pressures that
um
the industry is facing Financial
pressures so to get such
to capture such data at this time I
think is is vital and it's going to be
very useful thank you thank you um
councilor wetton are there any other
questions or comments on this item no
okay
um so can the recommendation in the
paper be agreed please
thank you okay
um item 10 is the Health and Care
um is sorry rather the establishment of
the GM integrated care partnership
committee it's actually listed as the
report of the chief exec I'm not sure if
it's just double Council Slater that is
setting that out Sarah
um thank you chair
um I think um probably not much to say
to the report really and the reason it's
me is because it is recommending that um
councilor Jane Slater become Our member
representative on the integrated care
partnership
um I could spend quite um a deal of time
talking about the change in
organizational Arrangements that we've
seen during the course of this year but
um as a report explains we have moved
from a situation where we have clinical
commissioning groups ccgs who are
commissioning care
um to an arrangement that has a greater
Manchester integrated care system which
will have some governance around it and
one aspect of that governance is the
integrated care partnership so this
report is seeking approval to have our
representative at that integrated care
partnership as as councilor Jane Slater
in the context of her portfolio role
with councilor Andrew Weston the leader
of the council as the deputy probably
not say much more than that but happy to
take any questions thank you
thank you questions or comments from
members of the executive questions or
comments more widely
okay so um with that can the
recommendation set out in the report be
agreed please
thank you item 11 is the greatest
Manchester jointly now scrutiny
committee councilor Williams please
thank you Chad apologies uh thank you
chair I'm not going to speak at length
to this item as the reports and
recommendations are pretty
self-explanatory
um as you and others will be aware chair
following a legal challenge central
government received we were tasked as
local authorities in Greater Manchester
with producing a plan to improve our
quality across the connotation
10 local authorities in Greater
Manchester have coordinated this work in
a combined effort via gmca and It
produced a clean air plan which has been
submitted to government for
consideration as this work continues it
is proposed that a scrutiny committee be
established to execute oversight over
any decision-making moving forward by
the mechanisms that were outlined in
Pages five and six of the report the
recommendation for members this evening
is the executive consent to the
formation of antratford's participation
in said scrutiny committee thank you
chair
thank you um Council Williams any
questions or comments from members of
the exact questions or comments more
widely councilor jokin please thank you
later
um just as I really welcome uh that this
is happening
um it is it's very important for his
work the only question I had was on the
um decision of who that member was going
to be uh is going on has the process
been decided so who's going to be
attending uh is it is it from uh is it
the report says it's someone from who's
not in the decision-making capacity on
already
um so is does that mean it's somebody
from the controlling group or is it
somebody from someone a party that isn't
in control if not if it is somebody from
the controlling group is do we then have
a mechanism to feed into that to provide
the scrutiny that we desperately need
counseling
it's not fully clear from the report it
will require a review a great
manchester-wide level to determine
political uh proportion
um uh in terms of the committee places
um so once we have that clarification I
can provide you with that we've got a
meeting of the quality Administration
committee on Wednesday so I will begin
those questions about your V battery
Council thank you thank you
um any other questions or comments on
this
no okay recommendations are as set out
and Report can they be agreed please
thank you item 12 is modern slavery
councilor Harding please thank you
leader
Port um
introducing new measures to ensure that
public bodies tackle modern slavery
risks in Supply chains and as part of
this local authorities will be obligated
to publish a modern slavery statement
this isn't something that Trafford
Trafford Council currently has but
contained within the body of the report
is a draft a modern slavery statement
which would like to be published on the
website and also a list of recommended
actions that could be taken on Modern
slavery
so as of 2021 it's a requirement for
organizations with a budget of 36
billion or more in all sectors to
publish their modern slavery statements
as I've just mentioned Trafford Council
currently does not have that we want to
make sure that we are compliant modern
slavery is a serious and hidden crime in
which people are exploited with criminal
game and we all know that poverty
actually increases the risk around
modern slavery it incl it includes
slavery and servitude forced and
compulsory labor and human trafficking
we have to do better at reporting
Gathering data and notifying the home
office of potential victims
um research has been conducted and
traveled Trafford Council teams
contacted to understand what work we are
currently doing
um and there is work taking place across
Community safety adults children's and
Trafford strategic safeguarding
partnership licensing and trading
standards it's recommended that the
executive approve the content of the
Trafford Council modern slavery
statement outlined in the report and
note the intention to implement the
minimum recommendations number one to 14
and work towards more medium and
long-term activity over time thank you
leader thanks councilor Harding and this
is a joint report so just to check
counselors later if there's anything
that you wanted to add at all thank you
you later I just wanted to say Obviously
and the last but one Home Secretary and
so Allah reverman did say that they were
going to change the status of modern
slavery to that of illegal immigration
and we haven't heard anything
um from the current um Home Secretary
but I'm I'm glad that Trafford are
moving forward and I'm making this
statement because modern slavery isn't
illegal immigration and it needs to be
tackled and when we're in an environment
of poverty and economic decline people
are preyed upon and I'm so glad that
we're actually making this statement
this evening thank you leader thank you
councilor Slater any questions or
comments from members of the executive
questions or comments more widely
councilor but please
thank you chair uh I mean we also
welcome the Trafford Council statutory
compliance with the government's
legislation on Modern slavery clearly
any form of slavery or human trafficking
is not acceptable or if identical
identify in our supply chain uh the one
question I I need to ask actually 3.4
which is on the licensing side the
licensing team which record is a
licensed team are currently finalizing
their taxi statement of policy which uh
could include a statement on Modern
slavery uh appendix one uh is it
reference 19 is possibly a bit of a
confusing uh contradiction there which
says that it will include a statement on
Modern slavery in our taxi statement of
policy so I'm just wondering whether is
that just a an area or is that something
that's perhaps going to be definite at
that time
thank you thank you for your question
councilor but I'll clarify that with the
licensing officers and get back to you
with the written response thank you
thanks any further questions or comments
on this at all no okay recommendations
are as set out in the report could they
be agreed please
thank you item 13
urgent business
um I have none item 14 is the exclusion
resolution which I shall read
um that the public be excluded from this
meeting during consideration of the
remaining items on the agenda because of
the likelihood of disclosure of exempt
information which Falls within one or
more descriptive category or categories
of the Local Government Act 1972
schedule 12a as amended by the local
government access to information
variation order 2006 and specified on
the agenda item or report relating to
each such item respectively
um so ISO move is that greed thank you
okay if we can
um and the recording and thank you
that's great